We covered a lot of ground discussing different
synchronization algorithms for parallel machines, both mutual exclusion lock
and [INAUDIBLE] barriers, but now it's time to talk
a little about performance evaluation. As always designers, of
course, they're always concerned about the performance of these
algorithms, because all the applications that sit on top
of the processor. Is going to be using the algorithms
that you've designed. [INAUDIBLE] Designer. And so the performance
of these algorithms are very, very critical in
determining how good the applications are going to be performing.
So we looked at a whole lot of spin algorithms from, a very simple spin on test
and set to spin with delay and, spin.
Algorithms that respect the order of arrival of fairness
if you will. Starting from ticket lock and
the queue-based locks, all of these are different kinds
of spin algorithms that we looked at. And we also looked at a whole number
of barrier synchronization algorithms, starting from a simple
shared counter to a tree algorithm, to an
MCS tree. A tournament and dissemination. And I
also introduced you to several different kinds of
padlock architectures. Shared memory multiprocessor that is cache
coherent. Which may be a symmetric multiprocessor or
it could be a non-uniform memory access multiprocessor.
And you can also have non-cache coherence shared
memory multiprocessor. And of course, the last thing
that I mentioned to you, is the mul, message
passing clusters. So these are the different flavors
of architectures that parallel machines can be built
today. And the question you want to ask is,
if you implement the different types of. Spin algorithms
that I've been discussing with you. Which would be
the winner on these machine? Well the answer is
not so obvious. It depends really on the kind
of architecture. So as OS designers, it is extremely important
for us to take these different spin algorithms and
implement them on these different flavors of architectures. To
ask the question, which one is the winner? It
may not always be the same. Algorithm that may be
the winner on these different types of machine. And
the same thing you should do for the barrier algorithms
as well. So the barrier algorithms, all the way
from the counter to the dissemination barrier, all the different
flavors of algorithm. And you have to ask the
question, which would be most appropriate to implement on these
different flavors of architectures? As always, I've been emphasizing
that when you look at performance evaluation that is reported
in any research paper, you have to always look at
the trends. The trends are more important than the absolute
numbers because the dated nature of the architecture on which
a particular evaluation may have been done. Make the absolute numbers
not that relevant, but what is important is trends. Because
these kinds of architectures that I mentioned to you, they're still
relevant to this day. And therefore what you want to
ask is the question, if different types of spin algorithms and
barrier algorithms. When you implement it on different kinds of
architectures, which one of those algorithms are going to be the winners?
>> That completes the discussion of
synchronization algorithms for parallel machines. I
encourage you to think about the
characteristics of the different spin lock algorithms
and the barrier synchronization algorithms that you studied in this lesson. And
we also looked at two different types of architectures. One was a symmetric
multiprocessor, the other was a non-uniform memory
access architecture. Given the nature of the two
architectures, try to form an intuition on your
own on which one will win in each
of these styles of architectures. Verify whether the
results that are reported in the MCS paper
matches your intuition. Such an analysis will help
you very much in doing the second project.